c'est aujourd'hui le grand retour du
nothing phone on a connu l'année
dernière le nothing phone one qui était
empire une petite révolution mais quand
même un petit coup de fraîcheur au
niveau des smartphones avec un concept
un peu à part au niveau du design on va
donc se regarder aujourd'hui le dancing
fun 2 qui est arrivé là il va tout de
suite pour la présentation du nothing
phone tout
[Applaudissements]
mais avant toute chose pour bien
commencer on va commencer par l'unboxing
on va commencer par venir regarder tirer
cette languette alors ça c'est le truc
que j'aime bien je leur ai dit à nos
signes que j'ai vu l'autre jour quand
ils m'ont présenté le produit je leur ai
dit pourquoi est-ce que vous faites ça
comme ça moi j'aime bien garder mes
emballages de smartphone et là c'est pas
possible on va devoir l'ouvrir on va
devoir l'abîmer et je pense que c'est
vraiment ce qu'ils veulent c'est que
vous allez la vivre une fois et une
seule fois et pas deux fois c'est-à-dire
qu'une fois que vous l'avez vécu une
fois qu'il est démouler votre smartphone
et bien c'est fini si vous voulez
recommencer il faut en acheter un autre
n'allez pas en acheter un deuxième tout
de suite un start strictement rien on a
vraiment un côté très granuleux sous le
doigt là avec des espèces de voyez il y
a un peu de relief donc déjà il y a un
côté matière je pense qu'il va vraiment
nous emmener dans une expérience avec un
côté un peu un peu touché où nos sens
vont être en éveil alors derrière il y a
pas de sens en éveil et après là ça
vient s'ouvrir comme ça on vient
retrouver ce petit capot là dans lequel
il y a rien si ce n'est l'empreinte du
smartphone pour venir épouser le capteur
photo on voit déjà directement qu'on a
un double capteur photo mais ça
normalement si on suit un peu l'actu et
bien on le savait ici on va avoir bon de
la doc des choses comme ça on va
retrouver ici le câblage câblage nothing
avec le petit Picot pour venir ouvrir le
tiroir de carte SIM qui est très
différent de ce qu'on trouve dans le
reste du marché nothing veut toujours
être différent va être disruptif venir
changer les choses et là j'ai
l'impression d'avoir une petite diode en
fait une petite LED vous voyez et cette
année ils ont fait un truc c'est que ils
vous ont vraiment fait un câble de
charge usb-c usb-c alors il y a pas de
bloc de charge ça vous l'avez vu mais
surtout ce qui est cool et bien c'est
que il va être écrit nothing ici pas si
vous le voyez bien nothing c'est
transparent il joue la transparence donc
là ils nous mettent aussi des petites
icônes voyez sur le papier 3 secondes
pour l'allumer bouton de volume et vous
avez ici qui aura de carte SIM qui est
en bas et ici vous avez de quoi venir le
recharger en usb-c donc après
l'expérience se fait comme ça donc là je
viens d'ouvrir là vous allez vraiment
pris après ça se déchire un peu c'est le
papier hein OK et alors ce que m'a
expliqué nos signes ce qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est qu'en fait il y avait
des petits points de détails que de
problèmes de finition qu'ils avaient sur
le fun one vous avez dû faire des
compromis aujourd'hui sont les beaucoup
plus loin en compromis vous voyez il y a
des petites choses qu'on voyait avant
apparaître qu'on ne voit plus ils
gardent vraiment ce design avec la
glyphe interface avec différentes choses
mais je vais vous montrer dans quelques
instants le détail je le trouve top ici
top canon très différent donc
laissez-moi juste le temps de bien le
prendre en main de bien amuser avec et
je vous donne mon retour dans quelques
instants le temps d'un claquement de
doigt on a donc ces deux smartphones là
on l'a dans la version grise mais il
existe également version blanc comme
version blanche version blanche comme on
l'avait effectivement l'année dernière
la prise en main qui est très bonne il a
un poil large mais globalement ça fait
le taf ce que je vais aimer c'est ce dos
en verre bombé alors à savoir qu'ici
vous avez un Corning Gorilla glace 5 à
l'arrière mais également à l'avant votre
châssis qui en a lu 100% recycler alors
là par défaut ils vous ont mis un thème
sombre vous pouvez également avoir un
thème clair vous allez dans écran et
vous pouvez désactiver le thème son pour
avoir le thème clair personnellement je
vais quand même préférer le thème son
que je trouve plus élégant sur ce
smartphone là tout en sachant que vous
avez un écran en LED c'est du 6,7 pouces
ltpo qui va de 1 à 12 bon on connaît la
techno et pas toute nouvelle full HD+ un
milliards de couleurs je veux dire 10
plus qui va également lutter contre la
lumière bleue et qui va jusqu'à 1600
Nitz max autant vous dire que ça on voit
quand même du bois truc intéressant un
nouveau test cette année c'est le
processeur autant l'année dernière on
était sur un processeur milieu de gamme
autant là cette année ils ont vraiment
fait un gros focus avec un processeur
haut de gamme c'est le saint dragon 8
plus Jane 1 en gros c'est le processeur
le plus performant sur Android de
l'année 2022 alors vous me direz on est
en 2023 mais soyons clairs même si vous
prenez le processeur le plus performant
de l'année 2022 il ira parfaitement bien
en 2023 alors il existe dans deux
configs au niveau de la RAM soit 8 soit
12 et le stockage c'est soit du 512 soit
du 128 soit du 256 pareil la batterie
4700 mille ailleurs vous avez la charge
45 watts en filaire du 15 watts sans fil
et du 5 Watt inversé alors le truc qui
nous intéresse vraiment chez nosting
c'est ce qu'ils appellent la glyphe
interface c'est-à-dire en fait tout ce
travail qui est fait au niveau des LED à
l'arrière vous avez en tout 33 zones
d'affichage et en fait ce qui est
intéressant c'est que notamment au
niveau voyait de cette zone là ou de
cette zone là et bien je vais pouvoir
venir avoir différentes informations et
c'est là où ils vont plus loin par
rapport à l'année dernière ils sont suis
vraiment impernaliser toute la création
de nothingos 2.0 vous venez ici vous
allez dans Paramètres et vous allez
chercher la glyphe interface vous allez
pouvoir venir un peu tout paramétrer
déjà au niveau de les sonneries donc là
vous avez des sonneries par défaut vous
voyez vous avez plein de sonneries
différentes qui sont intéressantes aussi
bien au niveau de l'affichage sur votre
smartphone que au niveau
de la sonnerie alors voyez c'est du
nothing c'est très particulier moi je
trouve ça assez efficace
le dauphin Anna ok stick j'ai les
vibrations plus sur le doigt Wizard
c'est sorcier normalement Hammer
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est club après vous avez les
nothing machine pneumatique
pas mal ludique
c'est quoi ça un écureuil me semble-t-il
un peu de ça code
[Musique]
après le truc qui est cool c'est que
vous avez vos propres sur tous vous avez
le compositeur glyph ici et là vous
venez créer vous-même votre pop music
c'est différents types de sons je vais
avoir modèle genre bug je vais avoir 606
je vais avoir je vais avoir Dan et en
fait c'est des sons à chaque fois vous
voyez ça fait comme une petite batterie
donc je choisis ça par exemple et là
ensuite j'ai mon pas déjà composé
je mets bien la batterie 606 ça me fait
marrer
[Musique]
le problème c'est marié aussi
[Applaudissements]
votre propre morceau tout en sachant
est-ce qu'il y a plutôt cool ils vont
bosser avec des musiciens oui boss déjà
avec des musiciens qui vont venir
ajouter d'autres sons vous allez pouvoir
venir créer différentes musiques alors
après il y a les notifications
c'est très à part alors activation des
lettres bien évidemment activer le
glyphe mobile retournez donc vous le
retournez paf ça vous fait le petit
glyphe alors vous avez un minuteur aussi
je prends mon minuteur il marque placé
votre smartphone face contre terre pour
commencer je le prends je le place
contre terre et là j'ai mon minuteur qui
commence à renvoyer c'est du 15 secondes
donc là je vois vraiment l'écoulement
ici au niveau donc là vous voyez je vois
vraiment la progression et ça il pouvait
pas le faire avec le signe phone one ils
peuvent le faire avec la deuxième
version voyez c'est fini terminé on va
l'indicateur de volume également qui va
être là l'assistant Google réactivité
visible glisse affiche lorsque
l'assistant Google est activé donc vous
le voyez en bas indicateur de chargement
glyph progresse alors ça c'est vachement
bien parce qu'en fait c'est avec
différentes applications par exemple je
peux venir l'activer avec
uber ici donc lorsque je vais commander
un chauffeur et bien je verrai la
progression directement dans ma barre il
ira le chauffeur arrive ok je le vois je
commence mon smartphone sur l'horaire du
coucher également et puis après je vais
venir l'activer pour les notifications
pour avoir uniquement des notifications
essentielles pour avoir toutes les
notifications la glyphuntafizzair et la
vraiment un sens et puis nothing va
vraiment pour l'utiliser énormément pour
que ce soit vraiment cool autre point à
venir regarder c'est toute la partie
photo vous avez deux capteurs
grand-angle ultra grand-angle le capteur
grand temps que c'est un 50 mégapixels
c'est un capteur Sony c'est l'immx 890
ultra grand-angle c'est un capteur de
Samsung le smartphone par contre les
certifié uniquement IP 54 on a pas ici
dip68 bon c'est son prénom en terme de
choix en tout cas bon il y a un minima
une certification double nanocyme bref
un smartphone que je trouve cool une
fois de plus qui va vraiment dans l'idée
de ce que se propose un nothing ici avec
trois configurations différentes soit du
828 exclusif sur le site de Nothing
d'ailleurs je vous mets le lien en bas
dans la description si elle vous
intéresse qui est proposé à 679 euros
soit le 12 256 à 729 euros soit 12512 à
849 € et une fois plus ça vous intéresse
je vous mets le lien en bas dans la
description donc voilà pour ces
premières impressions amélioration des
finitions bonne prise en main hop voilà
large les bons globalement c'est pas le
premier pas le dernier il y a rien qui
me surprend bien ici très différent par
rapport à ce qu'on retrouve sur le reste
du marché les deux couleurs
personnellement j'aime bien les deux je
suis pas lequel vous plaît le plus
marqué le moi bien évidemment en
commentaire et on se retrouve très
bientôt pour vous donner mon retour
complet sur ce nothing phone to je vous
invite à venir à voir ma vidéo qui vous
présente les derniers écouteurs de
Nothing je vous le mets quelque part par
ici comme ça vous saurez tout et vous
allez voir elles sont hyper hyper canon
et ils vont très bien dans cet
écosystème que commence à construire
nothing voilà je vous embrasse prenez
soin de vous et à très bientôt Ciao